[Musique]
et on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à
mes côtés à nivat grand reporter de
guerre indépendant bonjour à mon jour
face à vous bruno daroux de la rédaction
de france 24 bonjour brunoh bonjour à
faire il dénonce une prise d'otage
volodymyr zelensky s'adressant aux pays
l'union africaine le président ukrainien
a clairement pointé du doigt le rôle de
la russie dans la crise alimentaire qui
couve actuellement écouter
l'afrique est prise en otage il s'agit
de la guerre de la russie contre nous il
ne s'agit pas d'une crise c'est une
guerre brutale
avez vous entendu tout cela de la part
de vos partenaires russes avec qui vous
êtes restés en contact je suis persuadé
qu'ils vous disent tout le contraire
mais il faut dire qu'ils ont besoin de
cette crise qui maintiennent sciemment
délibérément ils se servent de vous ces
sanctions ne sont là que pour empêcher
la russie de nous réduire en esclaves en
jeu 20 à 30 millions de tonnes de blé
ukrainien actuellement bloqués dans les
ports du pays depuis le début de
l'invasion russe un stock qui pourrait
grimper d'ici l'automne à 75 millions de
tonnes c'est autant de blé soustrait aux
marchés mondiaux à commencer par la free
bruno daroux c c'est une manière de se
dédouaner pour vous le dis mazet lenski
des effets de cette crise aux prêts
finalement des premiers pays dépendant
du bling craignent un oui c'est une
opération peu à double étage c'est à
dire effectivement se dédouaner dire en
fait bon on est désolés de cette
situation et des difficultés que ça vous
créé notamment en afrique et puis c'est
aussi une manière de dire en gros c'est
pas notre faute c'est la faute des
russes est donc de dire aux pays
africains dont certains se sont
rapprochés de la russie ces derniers
mois ou ces dernières années de leur
dire en fait ne vous trompez pas de camp
si vous êtes dans cette situation
difficile aujourd'hui et on voit le
président sénégalais la macky sall à
l'instant qui est le président de
l'union africaine en exercice qui s'est
rendu à sotchi il y a quelques jours
pour demander justement à vladimir
poutine de de faire quelque chose
d'essayer de se mettre d'accord avec les
ukrainiens et avec la médiation turque
pour que tout ce blé qui est bloqué
essentiellement à odessa puisse
emprunter la mer noire et traverser le
détroit de bosphore et le détroit des
dardanelles
voilà volodymyr zelensky fait à la fois
de l'urgence effectivement on se
dédouane ont ils fait quand même aussi
de la politique de la diplomatie leur
disant écoutez votre relation un peu
privilégié avec vladimir poutine
finalement ne vous trompez pas de camp
ce que le président russe est en train
de faire eh ben il le fait à vous aussi
et à vos populations
c'est important pour l'ukraine de
contrer le narratif rue sur ce continent
l'afrique labouré par moscou oui bien
sûr c'est important c'est capital c'est
ce que fait et les skis tous les jours
tous les jours clairement c'est hélène
ski qui crée l'agenda politique
international finalement aux graisses et
disco tout en s'adaptant justement au
public qu'il a en face et là bruno vient
de le dire
le président nuance week-end avait été à
sotchi mais c'est important de dire
qu'il avait été à sotchi ya quand même
plus de quinze jours donc il a été en
premier en russie et c'était quand même
dans son discours auprès de weber
poutine pour dire pour souligner le rôle
joué par la russie dans les
indépendances des pays des pays
africains donc il y avait il a choisi
quand même le représentant nu en
africaine a choisi d'aller en premier
voir vladimir poutine il avait promis
ensuite la symétrie mais asymétrie se
passe par vision c'est pas la même chose
par visio que dalle et physiquement à
kiev je crois qu'il avait dit justement
retour de sophie qu'il irait à kiev il
n'y a pas été il a fait ce visio et
zelensky effectivement essaye de les
convaincre alors que on voit bien que le
lait plus de 50 pays africains ne sont
pas unis
contre la russie il y en a qui se sont à
l'onu qui se sont abstenus il y en a qui
ont été en faveur et puis il y en a qui
ont été pour donc on voit on ne peut pas
parler d'une seule voix c'est compliqué
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous le
dis meireles qui se rend bien compte
qu'il faut aller leur parler lui même
même si ce qu'a proposé le président
sénégalais c'est à dire des discussions
pour que le déminage des portes des six
états pour que justement tout cela
puisse arriver partir en tout cas est
arrivé en afrique
depuis qu'il l'a proposé c'est à dire au
retour de sa visite de sotchi auprès de
venir poutine puisque poutine avait dit
qu'il n'était pas contre et rien ne
s'est passé et les discussions vous avez
ce qu'il a dit ce sont compliquées
comment expliquer bruno que macky sall
ne soit pas parvenu à convaincre la
dirco t-il d'une cause qui est quand
même bon il faut le dire assez assez
populaire l'idée de combat de cette
crise alimentaire mondiale tout
simplement parce que vladimir poutine
n'est peut-être pas animés des
meilleures intentions philanthropiques
et qu'il sait surtout qu'il détiendra
une arme de même qu'avec les européens
il alarmes du gaz avec les pays du
moyen-orient et d'afrique ils alarme
alimentaire mais à la rigueur si j'ose
dire ma le entre guillemets vraiment ce
sont un peu des victimes collatérales
parce que là en fait c'est un bras de
fer avec l'occident qui se poursuit par
ces pays un peu interposés c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs le président
sénégalais avait eu l'air de plus ou
moins soutenir la demande de vladimir
poutine à se lever une partie des
sanctions internationales petits navires
y écouter ci en gros vous arriver à
convaincre les occidentaux dont une
partie des succès internationaux contre
nous évidemment ça facilitera les choses
oui oui ça sent que la russie en paye le
prix en terme d'image auprès des
africains il arrive vladimir poutine a
rejeté la responsabilité sur les
occidentaux alors ça il faudra voir avec
le temps et c'est plein pourquoi la
lycéenne zelensky aujourd'hui faudra
également voir avec le torse que ça
produit sur les opinions africaines qui
sont pas majoritairement comédie d'anne
y avait ses parrains c'est pas un front
uni ces pays africains mais dans
certains pays africains du mouvement et
il ya une espèce de 2,2 faveur vis-à-vis
de de la russie parce que il ya le passé
effectivement où l'urss à l'époque à
aider ces pays vont sortir de la
colonisation
ça permet d'entretenir la défiance à
l'égard des des anciennes puissances
coloniales mais plus les semaines
passent plus les difficultés
alimentaires vont aller en augmentant on
verra comment tout ça évolue il faut
dire une chose aussi quand même c'est
que concernant le blessé quand même
surtout les les pays d'afrique du nord
du maghreb qui sont très touchés les
pays d'afrique subsaharienne ces puits
sont l'action des engrais puis il ya les
engrais aussi qui sont impactés par
cette crise et là ça ça va mais ça va
envoyer ça va impacter la production
n'en est pas encore là dans quelque
chose ça reste une menace 10 quelque
chose le marty salle le président
sénégalais quand il a été voir poutine à
sotchi ne peut pas convaincre seul c'est
pas vladmir poutine uniquement lui qui a
les clés en main pour dire mon masai et
maintenant je débloque les ports
n'oubliez pas qu'il ya quand même une
autre partie qui est très importante
c'est l'ukraine oui alors justement
qu'est ce qui a bloqué dans ces
négociations
d'ailleurs dans laquelle la turquie a
fait des propositions assez clair pour
permettre le de blessés est en train de
bloquer ce qui montre bien que ce qui se
passe cet enjeu de ces ports c'est c'est
la guerre c'est une continuation de la
guerre par d'autres moyens donc poutine
reçoit marty salle dit que c'est
peut-être possible etc mais ensuite il y
à des négociations qui commencent la
turquie comme vous venez de dire essayer
d'y prendre part en disant qu'elle
garantira le passage d'aidé parce que de
quoi de quoi le cred a peur le cren a
peur si elles des mines tous les ports
qu'elle a miné et bien évidemment qui
est une nouvelle offensive russe c'est
ça l'enjeu c'est le déminage pour
permettre le passage des bras qui espère
des navires qui transparaît fait que ça
a été miné protège l'ukraine or je vous
rappelle que le créa la russie sont en
guerre donc effectivement il ya des
conséquences économiques et sur la faim
dans le monde mais en premier lieu il y
à une guerre et c'est une nouvelle façon
de faire la guerre aujourd'hui il ya des
sanctions occidentales vis-à-vis de la
russie par rapport au fait que la russie
a renvoyé mais il ya des contres
sanction de la décontraction il y en a
sans cesse est-ce que c'est pas
aujourd'hui la nouvelle façon de faire
la guerre des mines et pour l'ukraine
s'est exposé son littoral un
débarquement amphibie des troupes russes
oui bah qui est visé c'est un des points
de blocage tout simplement parce qu'il
ya aucune confiance entre les ukrainiens
et roula les ukrainiens disent nous on
veut bien des mines et des russes aussi
d'ailleurs on me romy des mines de
comptes psn c'est compliqué mais je rien
disent nous on veut bien déminé sur
l'assurance absolue que les russes ne
vont pas en profiter pour lancer aussi
l'assaut contre au dessin à partir de la
mer puisque les mines sont surtout au
large au large de dessin donc comme les
ukrainiens n'ont absolument pas
confiance bien fait ils disent écoutez
des mines et non pour le moment c'est
actuellement un politique dans cette
affaire non pas les uns terrey des
ukrainiens au coeur en tout cas ce n'est
pas leur principale préoccupation sur
tout à fait ce que je pensais que ça
montre une fois de plus cette difficulté
que bono viennent souligner ce manque de
confiance montre véritablement qu'on est
encore en pleine guerre donc on n'est
pas les négociations vous souvenez du
début il ya quelques mois entre la
partie grillet la partie russe ont
complètement capoté hélas le fait que
justement pour régler un problème qu'il
ne les touche pas simplement elle
directement mais qui ont des
conséquences mondiales elles n'y
arrivent pas non plus donc ça veut dire
qu'on est encore très très loin
effectivement le problème vous l'avais
dit il ya actuellement 25 millions de
tonnes ça va continuer à arriver dans
les silos ray s'accumuler dans le port
d'odessa et à l'automne effectivement
les experts parlent de 70 75 millions de
tonnes ce qui est absolument énorme
reddition et là c'est à l'automne je
pense que va les voir vraiment une
gravité de cette néo sexe ça va se
traduire très très concrètement dans de
nombreux pays un tiers des ukrainiens en
tout cas sont aujourd'hui déplacés ou
réfugiés à l'étranger ça représente près
de 8 millions de personnes qui ont fui
un les frontière ukrainienne on en parle
quotidiennement ici sur france 24 mais
ils ne sont pas seuls ce 20 juin décrété
depuis une vingtaine d'années maintenant
j'en ai mondiale des réfugiés par l'onu
est l'occasion de rappeler le sort de
tous les autres pour l'année dernière ce
sont 90 millions de personnes au total
qui avaient été contraints de fuir leur
région leur pays et avec la guerre en
ukraine et bien le seuil des 100
millions de déplacés donc en passe
d'être franchi à titre de comparaison il
ya dix ans les nations unies ressent de
recenser moitié moins de déplacés 40
millions de personnes à travers le monde
pourquoi cette augmentation bono pas
parce qu'il ya eu davantage de conflits
alors localisé mais il ya eu tout
récemment l'afghanistan le yémen le sud
soudan la birmanie
donc effectivement ça crée à chaque fois
des flots de réfugiés qui viennent
s'ajouter à ce qui existait déjà sur des
conflits malheureusement qui dure depuis
le depuis plus longtemps comme la rdc
par exemple ou des situations très
compliquées d'où cette augmentation est
effectivement cette année avec le total
des réfugiés et déplacés ukrainiens ont
franchi quand même la barre des 100
millions vous l'avez dit à quelques
années on était encore à 48 ans est un
problème absolument essentiel et
il y a les réfugiés provoquée par les
conflits mais ce qui est également en
augmentation ce qui est pointé c'est
l'augmentation des réfugiés climatiques
à cause du réchauffement climatique soit
qu'il ya autour de 23 24 millions de ces
réfugiés climatiques donc c'est
peut-être aucun cas c'est peut-être
aussi ça qui a provoqué depuis dix ans
l'augmentation de ces réfugiés ce nombre
en augmentation quasi exponentielle and
il impose un changement de politique au
pays dits développés ah oui ce nombre
d'abord signifie que le monde est en
perpétuel mouvement et que personne ne
pourra jamais empêcher quiconque de se
déplacer et ça n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le haut commissaire pour les
réfugiés des nations unies filippo
grandi l'arrêt des guerres et des
conflits et le meilleur et le seul moyen
de lutter contre le déplacement forcé
donc nous sommes dans une situation de
crise mondiale les gens qu'on peut
construire tous les murs qu'on veut on a
déjà beaucoup débattu là dessus il ya
des murs entre l'américaine mexique y en
a ceux qui croient que ces murs
empêcheront les gens de passer et de se
déplacer se trompe et donc il faut
absolument penser aujourd'hui et à
l'accueil
l'accueil digne de tous ces réfugiés ce
n'est pas facile c'est d'ailleurs
souvent un domaine politique qui est
instrumentalisée par les uns et par les
autres on l'a bien vu dans la récente
campagne
présidentielle française
et il y a eu si on prend l'exemple des
ukrainiens récemment deux par cet afflux
de par le fait que cette guerre était
beaucoup plus proche et qu'elle a fait
peur à nos concitoyens à 1 accueillent
des ukrainiens qui a été différent avec
des procédures faciliter ce qui
s'appelle la protection temporaire et là
je rappelle que quand même énormément de
domaines jets se sont enfin on souligné
cela et ont questionné seul en se disant
que peut-être ces procédures facilité on
pourrait aussi les développer pour le
reste des réfugiés pas uniquement les
réfugiés les réfugiés c'était l'objectif
pour la france quel est le le le guay
qui qu'est ce qui fait finalement qu'on
est plus
sensible au drame qui touche les
ukrainiens ou peut-être bon voyage sans
doute alors plus accueillants craignant
une proximité géographique et culturelle
même si évidemment n'ose pas le dire
j'ose le dire c'était lequel clairement
après il faut rappeler aussi que les
pays puissent que vous posiez la
question de l'accueil les pays les plus
accueillants sont pas souvent les plus
les pays les plus riches et puis
développement les
plus proches l'union européenne a par
l'allemagne qui s'en sort pas trop mal
si j'ose dire d'autres pays y compris la
france non pas une politique d'accueil
hyper dynamique quand on compare
justement à ce que font bas actuellement
des pays comme la pologne ou la roumanie
avec les ukrainiens le nombre de
réfugiés qui accueille la turquie 4
millions de réfugiés dans là plutôt
syrien sur le sol turc ce sont des
chiffres qui nous touche et nous nous
paraîtrait enfin mettrait marine le pen
au bord de l'infarctus et voulait donc
pourtant ces pays là font cet effort
alors ce ne sont pas les pays les plus
riches ça nécessite une politique
concertée au niveau de grands ensembles
régionaux l'a beaucoup dit par exemple
de l'europe une forme de régulation à
l'échelle européenne et qui se pose peut
être aussi dans des régions touchées
directement on pense au pays frontalier
de la syrie ou de l'afghanistan mais moi
ce que je veux dire c'est que justement
quand j'ai couvert pendant des années la
guerre en irak la guerre en syrie la
guerre en afghanistan et qu'il y avait
déjà ce problèmes de réfugiés ce
problème de l'accueil évidemment il
n'avait pas il ne recevait pas le même
accueil que les ukrainiens aujourd'hui
et pour répondre un peu abruptement à la
question vous avez posé précédemment je
pense que le fait il faut le dire que
les réfugiés ukrainien ne soit pas noir
qu'il soit blanc soit donné à ma
religion voilà qui n'est pas la religion
de l'islam qui n'est pas musulmane joue
en leur faveur donc effectivement on
s'est peut-être explicable je ne sais
pas en tout cas moi c'est quelque chose
que j'ai du mal à comprendre mais il
faudrait réfléchir là dessus parce que
forcément ça va provoquer des tensions
il ya déjà beaucoup de réfugiés qui ne
sont pas des réfugiés ukrainien qui le
ressentent donc bien sûr il faut une
politique
d'union il faut
homogénéiser les politiques mais
ça ne va pas être facile puisqu'on a
déjà
au sein de l'union européenne des
divisions dans la compréhension de ce
conflit et sa réaction entre c'est très
différent entre la façon dont les pays
baltes et la pologne réagissent au
conflit par rapport disons aux pays de
plus de l'europe dû sud dont fait partie
la france l'italie et même l'allemagne
et c'est donc et pour juste et pour
boucler la boucle l'actuelle crise
alimentaire qui est peut-être pas voulu
mais en tout cas instrumentaliser un peu
quand même par l'annuaire poutine risque
d'accentuer ce phénomène puisque dans
quelques mois ça pourrait augmenter le
nombre de personnes qui vont quitter
leur pays non pas pour des raisons
politiques non pas à cause de conflits
mais tout simplement à cause de la faim
pour aller se nourrir à mayer est allé
notamment si la crise n'est pas réglée
alimentaire et l'on va vers ça puisqu'on
le 18 août l'affairé plus en plus de
réfugiés se déplaceront avec une
instrumentalisation de ce problème via
poutine l'a déjà montré avec son allié
biélorusse était d'ailleurs à l'origine
de cette crise lui a nié le tout début
absolument on s'en souvient tous quand
ces réfugiés étaient bloqués à la
frontière et que justement il avait dans
l'intention la propagande était de dire
que vos las de faire peur de dire que
vous allez vous devoir les accueillir
donc on en est là on en est à même cela
c'est à dire c'est vraiment la honte
absolue l'instrumentalisation de la
souffrance humaine c'est ça cette crise
des réfugiés et c'est pour ça je pense
qu'il faut que ce cette journée a été
créé pour faire en sorte qu'on en parle
et qu'on se rende compte du problème est
que nos lits que nos dirigeants
politiques se rendent compte que il faut
qu est-ce que c'est nécessaire parce que
ça nous touche tous et ça va augmenter
les tensions si on y réfléchit pas merci
on y va à mercier également à bruno
daroux c'était on va plus loin prochain
journal dans trois minutes rester avec
nous dans paris direct